elle est revenue vraiment je vous le dis
je vous jure elle est revenue pour moi
ce que je lui ai demandé j'ai fait un
appel
vous l'avez vu vendredi à l'antenne et
shy'm a dit oui merci shine est là
[Applaudissements]
j'avais considéré qu'il n'avait pas été
à la hauteur lors de notre dernière
danse et ça il ne pouvait pas laisser
passer ça donc dans un instant là là
dans les quelques secondes qui vont
suivre
shy'm milhas et l'animal shy'm et mia
j'aimerais que pour les téléspectateurs
ce soir on fasse une danse voilà
vraiment mis une belle danse mais ont
choisi vous avez choisi un titre
on a choisi pendant la pub vous avez
choisi déroulé comme je peux vous dire
que les gens que tu es sénia faut faire
parce qu'on sait pas si les gens les
gens se rendent compte qu'à un moment de
paix et l'aquarelle et 3 me semble
attention c'est parti
moi je vous suis
[Musique]
lannoy
l'opération
[Applaudissements]
non
là
[Musique]
je me souviens
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors oui
[Musique]
on allait rester calmes mais paraît
cette fin une haletante
ouais moi je me suis concentré sur la
femme sur la fin l es deux est
franchement laid du reste mais ce n'est
pas propre à l'adresse commence à tout
mettre à danser ça va les gêner
et pendant un bon soir et britney spears
et madonna
il ya eu shy'm et mia ouais est ce que
le troisième groupe buzz à la télé deux
hommes qui s'y